[Applause]
in Germany an old threat with a changing
face
the far right has been named the biggest
danger to democracy here
while some extreme groups are easy to
recognize two hours outside Berlin a
less well-known Community is also being
monitored by the authorities
this is the headquarters of the kingdom
of Germany
um so this is my IDE yes I need you part
of a self-proclaimed independent state
where I need a visa to visit oh so just
one day yep
how do I address you and today I'm
meeting their self-appointed King what
do we say then king of Germany so I say
your majesty
the authorities list them as extremists
who want to take control of Germany and
overthrow the current system so you've
got own driving license own identity
card own passport yes own currency own
own own Bank King uh this is the bank
this is the bank with around 5 000
current members
King Peter has dreams that eventually
every German will join
and are these new people or current
members this is a new people wow so
you're expanding yes yes
the German intelligence agencies class
the kingdom as part of a growing
reichberger movement 23
000 people who reject the legitimacy of
the post-war German state
in December 25 people were arrested for
plotting to storm the Parliament and
overthrow the government
while King Peter wants change he says
his group would never use violence is
reisburger coup plot failed but more
than 38 000 people across Germany are
now classified as right-wing extremists
14 000 are thought to be violent a major
concern for the authorities University
of far fewer Democrats
hours
we were attacked
victims of the far-right agree Suleiman
Malik has been trying to build a mosque
for more than a decade in the East
German state of thuringia as well as
receiving death threats one day he
arrived to find this this is a pig head
and this is what I found here when I
came pork scattered around the planned
place of worship do you think there
would be a lot of support if there was a
coup that installed a right-wing
government yes there will be you think
there is yes there will be there is why
because they see that this is the
solution we saw the pictures in USA
this can happen here as well
Solomon is particularly worried about
the rocketing popularity of the afd a
far-right party with 78 seats in
Parliament which is soaring in the polls
at this rally extremist Bjorn herca
tells the crowd Russia is their friend
this year charged with using a Nazi
slogan he and the party are also on the
domestic intelligence watch list
are you divisive are you dangerous
this is
but opponents disagree around the corner
left-wing supporters have launched a
counter protest
Loki says right-wing ideology has
divided her family and is splitting her
country in two we have to take action
now we have to defend democracy here
history has shown the terror Unleashed
by an uncontrolled far right in Germany
amid growing discontent the danger is
extremism could dominate again
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Germany thank
you